the Joe Rogan experience I let them ask
you this
my necks Perriman imagine you have no
martial arts training
none take everything you've learned
throw it away ok
take away all your physical training ok
you walk into a room full of people how
do you feel psychologically a little
insecure insecure and secure yeah that's
how regular people feel most people I
should say most they never trained in
their life they're unskilled to deal
with the situation that might occur or
occur at any moment you know yeah it's
it's such a gift to Treena
like I train all my students my my kids
mandatory training to a certain level is
mandatory
it's like mathematics is mandatory to a
certain level you can in Canada you
can't say oh I won't drop out of high
school not illegal no if I remember
illegal drawbars I'm not sure I think it
is now or they're gonna pass it but it's
like you need a certain level of
education and I'm not sure enough high
schools like let's say elementary school
okay you can't you can't drop out of
elementary school high school though I'm
not sure a double check but I'm pretty
sure it's illegal now at this point well
I think that would stop a lot of
bullying and I've said this before I
think it's counterintuitive to people
they think that bullying is a mean
person and if you taught them how to
fight they become meaner hmm but that's
I don't think that's the case I think
bullies are insecure yes I think if you
took away that and they got to really
establish through training that they
have character and that they're worth
something and they don't have to be
insecure and they build up this
confidence you wouldn't see them going
out and picking on people I've had so
many parents tell me I don't recognize
my son when he's with you
he's so disciplined and he's so kind he
soft spoken he's like at home he's an
animal he's a he's a like he acts up
he's yeah I'm like really well here if
he did that it would be a problem you
know it's like people respect right the
dojo they respect the environment
they're in because there are other guys
out there they'll put you in line yes
and that's the real world and some
people they don't know that like I
remember one time I was an airplane and
a guy punched the back of my seat I
swear to God I leaned back he had a
laptop on his tree yeah when I leaned
back it
crushes the laptop I don't know that guy
has a laptop I'm allowed to leave my
seat back and lean the back think I
pushes like he he palmed that heart like
poom and I was like excuse me sir
there's a problem he's like don't lean
your chair back I'm like whoa I'm like
this is a guy who's never gotten a
beating in his life the way he talked to
me was so rude I was like I would never
talk like that somebody never why
because you learned through martial arts
you know they like respect everyone men
respect is huge one day or the the
hunted one the other day you're the
hunter and it's just like the way life
works you know like have respect why
should like this guy's instigating a
fight now we know what violence is it
could get so it could be really bad for
one of us here like why would you want
to go there just say a laptop yeah you
just say I would have been like
sorry sir my fault my apologies I
thought about the guy bottom whatever he
wants like anything I would I would have
took care of it like I would have been
nice to him about it because we know the
realities of violence like some people
don't know the realities of violence
like I've seen people like on video they
like they're in a certain situation and
act all crazy
this might spark some violent event here
yeah like you don't want this you don't
know what violence is you've seen it on
TV you seen in a movie you think what
you think you know what it is to be
punched and kicked and like this could
end really bad for you like would you
want to play with that if you know what
it was like sometimes I see people
starting a fight I'm like this person
has no idea what they're talking about
like they've never been in a fight
they're instigating a fight a fight
might occur and they might regret it
like they don't know what it is to be
hit to be attacked to be to be in a
fight so like I just find I find always
like jaw dropping but somebody's gonna
instigate a fight over something so
small and they don't even know how to
fire which is even crazier I told that
guy off so bad did you oh you know I
told him off so bad I scared the hell
out of him and I was like yo what are
you know and he was like he turned white
I'm like dude like I could have been an
old lady here yeah you could have hit an
old lady she pulling her chair by I told
them off like I'm not wearing her
airplane - so I told him off like I
didn't yell or anything but I told him
office I told me is a real you know I
told what I think of him that guy shut
his mouth but it's like dude you want to
fight over this laptop like seriously
like that's no one can possibly know
that you have a laptop open no but in
fact you palm someone's chair be a man
when I'm in public the last thing I want
was fight yeah of course last thing I
got out of my system well isn't it funny
like when was the last time you saw a
fight at the gym never never maybe
occasionally some guys get mad if some
guy doesn't let go absolutely thing a
little thing yeah anything but it's it's
rare yeah but a bar Jesus Christ every
weekend I'm go fight the worst place to
be it is you understand what it is and I
think most people don't and I think most
people are scared of it and I think
that's why they posture that's where
they puff your chest up that's why they
pretend but most people have zero idea
most people that haven't had any sort of
physical altercation they have zero idea
of how vulnerable they truly are I just
don't know how this is there's this left
turn I take to the gym that people think
it's illegal like my wife when I did it
once she's like it said this illegal
turn I'm like no it's not I've
videotaped the light there's two green
lights going left I'd sent it to her and
I call okay you're right I think that
left turn twice a day every day to go to
the gym one day I take that left turn
and this guy races this car towards me
like he's gonna plow through my door
honks at me starts telling me off I'm
like I opened my car door I'm like let's
go you want to go the guy is he got
scared I'm like dude you you you're like
talking to me like you're my father here
you want to go and it was like turn away
he didn't want to come out of ascribing
shut your mouth it's not an illegal
light I get in my car and I leave but
that guy was mr. tough guys never been
in a fight in his life
now that it's you know he's in his car
he's safe and I hate stuff like this
[Applause]